hey everybody it's Mike freder here with
on call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week this week we're talking about cmmc
control si. L1 d3.1 14.1 hooray we made
it to the final control family number 14
identify report and correct system flaws
in a timely manner let's get into
[Music]
it so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelm tired and alone
and sad trying to understand all the
cmmc def fars and nist s17 compliance
stuff you've got a big dent in your head
from banging against the wall until it
bleeds the good news is you're going to
be okay I I mean I think you're going to
be okay the brain damage I probably
can't solve but you have found the best
place you could be which is a new home
with us here at on call compliance
Solutions where we can help you
transform into your company's on call
compliance Hero Let's get a suction cup
and peal that dent out of our head and
jump into it that was going to go
somewhere really good but then it didn't
and then and then I'm left with this
well frankly this big dent in this video
but whatever let's let's let's Carry On
Carry On Carry On Let's jump into it all
right there is another control that is
uh going to specifically dictate how
your organization must respond when it
comes to managing risk and handling
security incidents in this case it's all
about timing it's not good enough to
just have some loose policy templates
that you haven't opened in like 4 years
you really need to have these policies
dialed in with time frames and
expectations so that before bad things
happen everybody knows what the
expectations are and how to react to
explain more let's go step by step
through the assessment criteria and see
Point by Point what needs to be in your
incident response plan and procedures so
what are they looking for they're
looking for one thing determine if the
time within which to identify system
flaws is specified how do we do that
well via the it operations policy whoa
Mike what's an IT operations policy well
it's something you've got to have to be
able to get through this all right uh in
our example we're going to say hey look
there's an SLA or a service level
agreement of 60 minutes or less to begin
remediation efforts on system flaws when
immediate reaction uh to any system flaw
which may affect cui okay again that's
how it should be done and if you're
scratch your head about how on Earth
you're going to get a real it operations
policy here's the great news all right
if you're struggling on all these
policies documentation Etc we can help
with that all right and to find out how
we can help the calls always free talk
about that in a minute but meanwhile
let's dive into the control uh the
assessment uh points and let's find out
what we got to do to solve this okay
first one is determin of system flaws
are identified within the specified time
frame uh answer implemented via notes
during information intake for it create
it ticket creation yes okay we're going
to sort of make a couple assumptions
here you got an IT ticketing system
maybe you do it a different different
way but this is how we're going to give
you a sample answer uh and probably the
most common way so again how are they
identified and within what specific time
frame your ticketing system is going to
help with that next assessment Point
determine if the time within which to
report system flaws is specified
Implement via the instant response plan
okay so the instant response plan is
essentially dictating how you're going
to get this done the next assessment
point is determine if system flaws are
reported within the specified time frame
again implemented via the IT service
ticket system ticket review audit
process and risk management standard
operating procedure again there's like
three different policies already in the
first three assessment points if you
guys don't have your documentation in
order that's when you know you really
need to bring us in for some help okay
great indicator that uh honestly the
time it takes to write these policies
we've probably got thousands of hours
into our pre-written policies that we
bring in and then we're still
customizing them to you fourth
assessment Point determine if the time
within which to correct system flaws is
specified uh implemented via our it
operations policy SLA of 60 minutes or
less to begin remediation efforts on
system flaws with an immediate reaction
to any system flaw which may affect CI
system flaw time to correlate to
correction SLA is within 24 hours or as
soon as possible again notice I'm giving
very specific amounts as we go through
and you should too so again your system
security plan excuse me you all of your
documentation needs to have very
specific times for how long it will take
to do each step of the process next step
of the process determine if system flaws
are corrected within the specified time
again uh this can be via the IT service
ticketing system ticket review audit
process and risk management sop all of
those are places you can specify times
so hey if you are like me and you're
scratching your head from time to time
trying to figure out what in the world
is going on right uh or if you're just
looking at how to do this and thinking
man this is really overwhelming the
great news is is that on call we work
with defense contractors just like you
who have had this DARS nist itar and
cmmc compliance stuff dropped in their
laps like a seagull on a sunny day and
we teach you how to level up and be a
proper on call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps great areas and
getting this solved all showing you how
to leverage compliance as your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on call compliance hero can
do for you looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit CMC
compliance secrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now if you love the content we're
putting out there for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better yeah baby smash that
subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance nerds roll it out or you can
just smash that subscribe Button as a
simple way to say thank you because we
really appreciate you guys watching our
videos we love putting this content out
here for free we don't charge a single
penny we do it have our own time all
right but subscribers make us happy and
they tell us we're doing a good job so
if you think we're doing a good job Mash
that subscribe button let us know that
you're out here and you're hearing what
we're saying we know there's a lot of
people every month that get to see us
we're stoked about it we love when we
get new subscribers hey until the next
compliance HP my friends stay safe and
secure out there hit us in the comments
below to let us know what you'd like to
know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next
[Music]
one